parce que c'est vrai que y'a plus en
plus d'agressions de mer actuellement on
en voit de plus en plus dans les médias
c'est incroyable les maires de plus en
plus pris pour cible et il ya une
agression qui fait froid dans le dos
dimanche soir alors qu'il se promenait
dans sa ville le maire de dourges près
de dijon a été très violemment agressé
alors qu'il avait demandé à un jeune
conducteur de quad de rouler moins vite
s'est fait tabasser par cette personne
armée c'est un acte terrible et qui fait
peur alors que le nombre d'élus agressé
augmente chaque année et ce soir francis
d'hulst maire de portbail
vous avez été agressée vous l'été
dernier c'était le 6 août dernier
vous vous rendez sur un campement
sauvage en l'absence des campeurs vous
déposer un message leur rappelant
l'illégalité d'installation et le
lendemain vous retourner sur les lieux
et ça se passe mal oui ça se passe mal
parce que lorsque je suis arrivé il y
avait 3 3 jeunes qui étaient installés
puis qui avait bien vu l'arrêté qui
avait été déposée sur la mais qui
n'avait pas du tout l'intention de
bouger
donc en plus il avait fait du feu à côté
d'une pinède en plein été ce qui était
quand même pas très jours ou semaines
voilà puis donc je leur ai simplement
dit que c'était irresponsable de faire
une chose pareille
et puis l'un des tous pareils j'étais
seul oui c'est une erreur ou l'arrivée
vous étiez le meilleur maire d'iwuy
savez oui c'est face ce n'était pas des
gens de la commune mais c'est quand même
des quartiers savait et donc
assez rapidement l'un des trois qui
semblait un peu plus énervé m'a dit
qu'il allait cramé ma voiture et que et
que donc à ce moment-là j'ai commis une
erreur je les subis par la suite j'ai
réalise appelle les gendarmes et je suis
allé vers ma voiture
et puis je me suis fait courser puis
j'ai reçu deux coups de deux coups de
poing derrière derrière la nuque mais je
m'en sort relativement bien non monsieur
sortir l'air qui mord bien pendant une
semaine quand j'ai un peu mal au crâne
mais par rapport justement à des
confrères bien sûr agrica à l'époque en
plus il avait un autre de dans la
gironde qui s'était fait aussi tabasser
assez durement avec des côtes cassées
etc et ça a été ça a été quand vous
dites j'ai comme une autre de dire de la
paix oui j'appelle les gendarmes oui
vous auriez dû peut-être partie rappelé
yvan d'art après voilà c'était alors oui
voilà depuis cette année j'ai fait
ainsi un stage organisé par le gign où
on nous a expliqué les choses à faire et
à ne pas faire et c'était un stage très
intéressant aujourd'hui nous ont dit
j'aurais préféré peut-être l'avoir eue
avant mais bon il reste d'abord déjà de
ne pas y aller seul deuxièmement de ne
pas dire à quelqu'un
j'appelle les gendarmes sur ses dires il
aurait fallu simplement que j'aille à ma
voiture et que j'appelle les gendarmes
sans sans le dire parce que c'était une
provocation nomination donc on se
retrouve mais ce qui est terrible c'est
qu'ils se retrouveraient dans une
situation où on nous dit mais c'est vous
qui avait provoqué mais c'est ça en mars
l'annoncé un peu sur la tête on marche
sur la tête de bélier on les appelle les
gendarmes considère ça c'est une
agression ça rapport à une personne
c'est ce que j'ai dit c'est par exemple
si vous avez pas ce que pareil quand on
quand on voit dans une gendarmerie pour
parce qu'on a été agressé on se retrouve
un peu comme vous dites adam dans la
situation d'une dame qui vient de se
faire violer à qui on va dire mais
attendez remettez vous aurez rhabiller
vous correctement de la bande me parler
quoi c'est c'était un peu j'avais la
peur de votre vie non parce que je suis
fan des arbitres
oui ça s'est passé très vite j'ai pas vu
parce que comme c'était découragés ils
ont été achetés par l'arrière quoi donc
j'ai reçu bien sûr et un coup on ne sait
jamais le résultat d'un coup une fois
qu'ils en turquie avant qu'il ne soit
donnée
donc c'est une situation qui
malheureusement à l'époque y avait
plusieurs personnes il ya eu deux trois
mères qui avaient lieu les 60 mère qui
avait déjà été agressé deux depuis le
début de l'année en 2020 alors je sais
pas mais pardon 1276 mère agressé en
2020 avait il ya déjà fort heureusement
vous l'avez signalé il ya 500 maires
déjà formé par le gign ou à l'arrêt à
ses 13 points de la négociation sur la
toile a essayé de calmer directement les
gens avant d'en arriver à des sur les
autres les albums physiques ont
progressé de 23% pour les mères
devraient porter plainte mais
l'agresseur principal avait d'abord été
mis remis en liberté avec un simple
rappel à la loi c'est exact mais c'est
ça qui m'a fait le plus mal c'est ça
parce que
se retrouver avec un simple rappel à la
loi je dois marquer sans remarquer que
j'ai lu ça la semaine dernière que le
garde des sceaux qui avait d'ailleurs à
l'époque la suite de toute cette
médiatisation autour des mers agressé
avait décidé de d'abord 2
de ne faire de faire cesser le rappel à
la loi sert qu actuellement normalement
il n'ya plus de rappels à la loi alors
est ce que c'est la semaine dernière
c'est quoi ces directives ont une image
au point ce cas une wii parce que
sûrement qui a une main grâce à tous les
médias d'ailleurs qui est intervenu sur
cette affaire et sur beaucoup d'autres
sur un contact d'ailleurs depuis avec
d'autres mères qui ont été qui ont été
agressés je dis pas qu'on va faire une
une association des maires agressé parce
qu'on serait peut-être un peu trop
nombreux mais mais mais mais en tout cas
il ya quelque chose à faire alors on se
sourit keynes et le maire 12 qui a été
agressée on va les regarder
dimanche soir après avoir interpellé un
conducteur de quad en excès de vitesse
jean-claude girard est agressé à coups
de barre de fer par un groupe de sept
personnes était blessée par un coup de
barre d'un objet métallique derrière la
tête alors que voilà quelqu'un qui est
arrivé dans mon dos j'ai perdu
connaissance
le maire de 58 ans s'en sort avec deux
jours d'incapacité de travail et des
séquelles psychologiques
la gendarmerie a lancé une enquête
l'association des maires de côte-d'or
demande des sanctions exemplaires alors
des sanctions exemplaires c'est vrai que
on se dit mais non agréé cerbère c'est
sacré c'est passé c'est comme si on
apprécie le représentant contre ça n'y a
pas de tabou dit ya juste eu un rappel à
la loi
c'est assez bizarre gilles verdez oui
normalement il peut y avoir une plainte
une enquête et puis une condamnation
mais très souvent comme les maires sont
dotés de pouvoirs de police
on estime que c'est à eux d'intervenir
et vous êtes lâchés dans la nature est
aujourd'hui monsieur être mère ça
devient trop dangereux
c'est risqué oui oui c'est vrai que je
pensais que je suis père de famille
grands et même grand père et même
arrière en pertes mais par la queue
oui de la mer c mais je reconnais que je
reconnais que franchement vous êtes
arrière-grand-père oui c'est incroyable
oui depuis peu de temps mais margot
comme on dit à dijon je voulais
m'excuser parce que justement donc si
vous voulez qu'on tournait quand on a de
la famille on considère quand on voit
des jeunes qui pourraient être nos
petits enfants
on pense pas que hélas à la danse relève
à vous taper dessus
je ne sais pas exactement c'est ce que
vous dites c'est vrai qu'on se dit il
n'a rien certain respect même et ça j'ai
l'impression plus en plus de gens sinon
comment deux fois je vois des agressions
de 75 c'est incroyable ça c'est des
choses qu'on voyait pas avant juin
désolé s'est il y avait un respect on
dise sa part attend d'aaron sa forêt sur
la jamais quoi la réalité ça va être mon
père ça pourrait être mon grand père
tellement jamais ont levé la main sur
une personne voilà âgées et c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui je vois de plus en plus
d'agressions de personnes âgées et ça ça
me rend fou il a été tourné au drame
rappelons-nous en 2019 sa mère qui est
décédée
bien sûr ce qu'il avait simplement
demandé à des personnes dans une
fourgonnette qui descendait des graves à
l'endroit et il s'est fait tuer c'est le
maire des saignées dans le var vous
allez on va avoir un vrai problème parce
que on n'arrivera plus à trouver des
mères très amer c'est vraiment un grand
soin c'est à dire qu'il est plaisant
aurait d'abord il est responsable
pénalement il est présent quasiment 7
jours sur 7 sur le terrain vous demandez
à monsieur qui peut vous répondre sur ce
qu'il a et sur ce qu'ils gagnent il fait
pas ça pour l'argent m'a tout de suite
c'est assez incroyable quand même du
tourisme du réseau les gens sont en
train de prendre
il y aura jamais une explosion de
violence mais surtout ce qui représente
l'état en fait les maires les élus les
policiers les pompiers et quand il ya
par dont jean marie bigard qui dit crève
kaunas à propos d'une ancienne ministre
et ben pardon ça participe de cet accord
partis là-dessus non c'est pas c'est un
autre sujet non c'est exactement le même
sujet doit écouter beau mais là on peut
remercier la même depuis vous avez votre
stage au gign reste que vous avez été de
nouveau confronté à ce genre d'outil que
non non non non mais deux choses déjà je
n'irai pas seul j'ai fait l'erreur d'y
aller seul mais j'étais déjà allé la
veille avait avec les gendarmes qui
passait dans le coin je n'ai envoyé sur
place ils s'y étaient pas lendemain dans
l'après midi j'avais dit tiens je vais
aller voir si simon arrêté fonctionner
sur une partie et cette fois il y était
mais j'aurais pas dû y aller ce non mais
on marche sur la tête les mêmes sommes
obligés d'aller est-ce que c'est ma mère
qui est henry est ce que vous pouvez lui
dire d'attendre un peu
la persistance du maire de corbeil en a
vendu est vraiment francis leloup la vie
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de
téléspectateurs ce soir qui ont craqué
mais je m'ennuie parce que vraiment moi
j'y vois là il faut s'assurer
franchement je comprend pas comment tout
agressive et la personne comme vous ça
me semble vraiment ça m'énerve
énormément voilà je vous le dis si on
espère que ça se reproduira plus il ya
vraiment des bâtards
très belle analyse francis en tout cas
remercier votre témoignage laissé et
vous avez été formidables
merci beaucoup